Jon Stewart has a uh he has a pretty
good new program I have to tell you the
thing he did in the middle there after
The Daily Show it wasn't so good this
new thing is very very good and Jon
Stewart has done some extraordinary
interviews recently uh Jon Stewart
interviewed a Mark bernovich he's the
Attorney General of Arizona and he
interviewed him about all sorts of
different claims of so-called election
irregularities fraud Etc
and this is just a little bit of a
preview the full interview is going to
be out over the weekend I believe take a
look at this and as good as a job as Jon
Stewart does focus on the lack of
serious thinking that Mark burnovich
displays here right now we have about I
think almost 20 criminal cases related
to the 2020 election out of four million
votes yeah no I I'm talking in fact John
but the reality is is there are millions
of people not only in Arizona but people
throughout this country that think the
election is stolen there's people that
believe in angels but that doesn't mean
you launch an investigation that Angels
change ballots that's a really important
thing
because all these Mega people that I
interview and they say we we just want
to know for sure we just want a forensic
audit which they can never Define we
want this that and the other thing so
that we can really be sure
the level of Investigation
needs to correlate to the level of
evidence for irregularities and again
when this guy says we we have 20
instances that we're investigating here
20 cases out of 4 million votes it
doesn't warrant the degree of spending
and resource allocation that they have
been doing a bit of a tautology
when you have a former president
spreading rumors yeah to his supporters
for instance Trump can say
74 000 mail-in ballots received that
were never male magically appearing
ballots 168
000 fraudulent ballots printed on
illegal paper 36
000 ballots illegally cast by
non-citizens now the truth is none of
that was real when it first came out the
Cyber ninja said Joe Biden won Arizona
and then they got a lot of pushback and
they started hedging and Hauling and
then next thing you know people are like
well brenovich needs to do something
about it and then it was like the hot
man you've responded by doing things
about it you what I've done is Ed you're
still investigating we've run it we've
run a lot of the stuff to ground and
when you get it to ground will you come
out and say Donald J Trump is wrong
the election in Arizona was fair not
stolen and not fraudulent I I I've
always been a straight shooter and once
no all once all the facts and evidence
for John John come on man I'm telling
you you have found no evidence that the
election in Arizona was fraudulent or
stolen from Donald Trump Donald Trump
lost Arizona period I've said that from
the very beginning there have been
isolated incidences thus far that we've
identified yes and we are Prosecuting
yes we still have some active
investigations going on but people can
draw their own conclusions no no it's
how can you draw your own conclusions
about facts no no people cannot draw
their own conclusions that's the point
of the law yeah it is the law is that
you have facts right and you have
fiction right the fact is the election
in Arizona was well run not fraudulent
and not stolen from from Donald Trump
according to even your investigation I I
have never said why is it so hard to
just say yes to that I just I guess
because I've spent my entire most of my
career as a prosecutor and we still have
some ongoing cases but he could say up
to this point I have found no legitimacy
to any of the claims so in your mind you
still feel like after all this you're
gonna discover no a concerted effort to
steal the election from Donald Trump and
and that it was fraudulent is that what
you're saying no that's not what I'm
saying so why can't you say the election
in 2020 was not stolen or fraudulent I
will tell you this as I said this is
blowing my voice yeah it is mind-blowing
and this is not some random Kook I mean
he's a kook but what I mean is it's the
Attorney General of Arizona
and it should be it it's very scary that
even he can't just say
it's over
it's over there was nothing here one
other thought
one of the lines they continue to use is
we need to investigate because a lot of
people aren't confident
that it was all on the up and up
but the reason that those people aren't
confident is because of Lies told to
them by those who want an investigation
right Trump goes we can't trust the
results I really want Arizona
uh ballot dumps toilet ballots uh
ballots and sandwiches ballots with
barbecue sauce that is not not native to
the United States you know all this
crazy stuff
so people go wow we really need to
investigate then Trump goes look the
people want an investigation yes but
they want it because of the lies you've
told them and it becomes circular uh
this is going to be a really good
interview I look forward to seeing the
full thing um and you can see the clip I
played today on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night